طبعا احنا اليوم متواجدين عن اقدم بائعي
البليله في مدينه جده وبالتحديد من كورنيش
جده الشمالي
ونتعرف اكثر عن بدايه العم عبد الله في
بيع البليله اللي صارت بالنسبه له
ليس مجرد مهنه او مصدر رزق فقط بل شغف ولا
زال من طفولته الى اليوم يوقف على هذا
المشروع وبنفسه يعطي البليله للزباين
عم عبد الله حدثني اكثر عن بدايه
اكيد البليله من الاكلات المحببه او خاصه
في منطقه جده او الحجاز بصفه عامه
صحتين انا اول
عبد الله لو تكلمني اكثر عن بدايه تكفي في
بيع البليله متى بدات وكيف كانت اذاعه
البليله
في الرياض
كنت ابيع حلاوه
واحد قال لي ما تروح السوق وتبيع غيري
[موسيقى]
بشريه
زمان الصندوق الصغير
شغالي
اذن الظهر روحت امي لما
[موسيقى]
اديلو فلوس
واشتريته
كم
بالساعه
والله
السلام عليكم
من الساحر
الساعه 12 حطيتها في القدر
قامت استوت في القامه
وديت لها مره ثانيه هي هي
قلت لها مع النار ذحين ينطبخ يروح
مع النار انت ما تشوف ابوك لما يسوي
الحلاوه البر اذا جات السوسه هذه نحن
نشتغل به قلت له يرميه خلاص خربان
كلام مستحيل
حطيت
المركب
[موسيقى]
ثلاثه حجار
لاول انه كنت همم تشيلها وتروح فيها
حطيت المركب وركبت البليله
المركب اي شيء
ايوه حطب
[موسيقى]
ما خمدات
سمعتيني يا حبيبتي
هيك مثلا بحكيها على صوت عالي للبيع
البليله يعني في جمله مشهوره بليله
بلبلوكي بالليل سلقوكي بنهار باعوك في
جمله بضل يعيدها مثلا عم عبد الله ليبيع
البليله على كورنيش جده الشمالي
طبعا عبد الله انت في خلال بيعه البليله
ايش اكثر العبارات اللي ترددها للزبائن
اللي يجوا عندك
بليله بالكمون ياكلها الشيب ولا ما عنده
سنون يعني مستوي في واحده مثلها هي بليله
والفول
[موسيقى]
بنت عم الفول
اذا خلصت ماني مسعود
تبع العروسه
العروسه
يبقى ليله بالطماطم عسى قلبك ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
ممكن تبون نديك انا زي ما قلت لك الكلام
الصحيح طب يا عم عبد الله ايش السر انك
يعني الدليل الذي حبيتها وصارت ما هي مجرد
مهنه فقط مصدر رزق صارت عندك شغف والى
اليوم انت لازلت توقف على مشروعك الخاص
وحتى كانك ورثت هذه المهنه لاولادك
لو تذكر لي الاسباب اللي الى الان انت ما
زلت انا بالرغم من النهايه يعني
عشان اشتغل وعشان امشي طيب حلو هو واحد
يقول لي تاخرت نص ساعه يعطيك العافيه يا
عم عبدالله
وتتوكل على الله شكرا جزيلا لك من جدا
يسعد صباح العربيه يا حنان